en esta lista de reproducción hemos
construido un sistema bancario monetario
que pues aproxima la verdad muy bien el
sistema bancario que usamos actualmente
así que pues a ver cómo empezamos
dijimos necesitamos un sistema bancario
sistema
bancario
lo que hicimos fue tomar el camino de
las reservas fraccionarias ya sabes
aceptamos algunos depósitos y nos dimos
cuenta que pues en realidad podía
quedarse un poquito guardado y el resto
lo podíamos prestar nos podríamos
prestar como el 90 por ciento o el 50
por ciento o algo así la cosa es que
sólo una parte lo manteníamos como
reserva y el resto lo podíamos prestar y
con este proceso pues se hacía un cierto
efecto multiplicador que generaba dinero
esto era el sistema de reserva
fraccionaria de reserva fraccionaria
reserva
fraccionaria muy bien y de lo que
hablamos originalmente cuando hablábamos
de reserva era de oro estaba basada en
oro habíamos empezado con los granjeros
quienes tenían cierto oro porque el oro
era el medio de intercambio primitivo la
gente se puso de acuerdo en usarlo y
siguió usándolo y después vimos que con
este sistema de reserva fraccionaria se
hacía un efecto multiplicador que hacía
que te convirtieras en una civilización
avanzada con una economía industrial así
occidental y entonces el oro se podía
quedar en las bóvedas del banco federal
nada más dando confianza en el sistema
pero únicamente eso verdad únicamente
dando confianza después creo que en el
vídeo pasado nos dimos cuenta que
podíamos salirnos totalmente del patrón
oro es decir usar una moneda que no
fuera dura o bien que no estuviera
respaldada por oro
por oro ok y el punto de todo esto es
llegar a la actualidad quiero mostrarte
que esto de aquí realmente no es tan
alocado hay muchas pues yo creo que
podemos llamarle teorías
conspiracionistas que piensan que había
malas intenciones detrás de salirse del
patrón oro ya sabes o sea así como que
en el fondo alguien se estaba quedando
con el dinero y bueno la verdad yo no
estoy 100% seguro de que estas teorías
sean falsas pero tampoco es como que
desde entonces haya habido una
destrucción masiva de la riqueza
correspondiente a una sociedad post
apocalíptica siendo sinceros el
crecimiento económico ha sido muy rápido
y ha habido innovación aumentó la
productividad y por tanto hasta donde yo
puedo decir creo que hemos tenido un
sistema económico pues bastante
razonable que no está respaldado por oro
sino que está respaldado por la riqueza
que puede generar un país por su
capacidad productiva pues en eso
estábamos en el vídeo pasado cuando creo
que pase por un punto sensible de esto
de que logré en realidad no está
haciendo nada simplemente está ahí como
un pues como un medio de intercambio
entonces algunas personas brincaron y
dijeron no es que el oro si vale algo
y entonces yo no puedo imaginar una
realidad en la que el oro no valga nada
el oro controla otros activos y pienso
que es bueno en que pensemos en que
otros caminos pudimos haber tomado en
este árbol genealógico de los sistemas
bancarios y luego que pensemos o más
bien que repasemos acerca de este
concepto del oro bueno entonces pensemos
en estas cosas vamos a empezar con el
oro porque creo que es pues lo que más
les inquieta a muchos de ustedes hay dos
conceptos entre los cuales estaba
haciendo una distinción y es una
distinción filosófica pero creo que es
muy muy importante creo que en el fondo
nos dice pues algo acerca del mundo
entonces está el dinero
dinero y luego está la riqueza
ahora estudia que es un poco truculento
porque finalmente solo son definiciones
y las definiciones pues van cambiando
con el paso del tiempo por ejemplo
busquen riqueza en wikipedia y me salió
la definición de adam smith la de su
libro la riqueza de las naciones si mal
no recuerdo habla de la tierra y del
labor que producen alguna utilidad para
el ser humano
bueno palabras más palabras menos algo
que va en ese sentido pues esencialmente
con su definición la riqueza serían
cosas como tierra comida refugio también
sería transporte
sería pues entonces también podría ser
entretenimiento claro hasta cierto punto
esto hace una utilidad en el sentido de
que nos hace un poco más felices
o bien también pueden ser cosas que
ayudan a producir estas cosas como
fábricas o no sé tal vez computadoras
cosas que nos ayuden a producir esto de
manera más eficiente vale pero si nos
quedamos en esta forma de pensar el
dinero no es riqueza por si mismo sino
un medio para intercambiar la riqueza es
un medio
y medio de intercambio y bueno sí o sea
podemos decir que el dinero tiene cierto
valor su valor es que funciona más o
menos como como el aceite para la
economía si no tuviéramos dinero
tendríamos que estar haciendo trueques a
cada rato y no sé si yo fuera un
arquitecto y quisiera obtener pan
entonces tendría que vender una casa y
obtener a cambio pues como diez mil
pedazos de pan super impráctico con
dinero puedo cambiar mi casa por dinero
y luego ese dinero por pan bueno dentro
de este contexto de usar dinero pues hay
distintos tipos de dinero verdad está el
dinero en papel
y dinero en papel
papel hay moneda dura etcétera
el oro entraría en este contexto
ahora aquí va una pregunta pues bien
profunda es el oro así en el fondo
intrínsecamente más valioso que el
dinero en papel y si lo pisas tantito la
respuesta de esto tiene que ver con lo
que crees que vaya a suceder mira el
beneficio o tal vez la parte negativa
del oro o de cualquier otra moneda dura
es que ese escaso es escaso y por ser
escaso pues pues no es como que puedas
imprimir más de esos así todo el tiempo
va a haber una cantidad específica de
oro va entonces si alguien quiere ver la
parte negativa de esto pues la escasez
quería decir que es menos flexible menos
flexible
o si quieres ver la parte positiva es
que no puede ser manipulado no puede ser
manipulado
y pues sí la verdad estas dos son
ciertas ciertas hasta cierto punto pero
pero a fin de cuentas eso es solo lo que
es es un medio de intercambio escaso
ahora no estoy diciendo que en algún
futuro el oro pierda la capacidad de
adquirir algunas de estas cosas de ser
intercambiado por estas cosas lo único
que estoy diciendo es que el oro o el
dinero es fundamentalmente distinto a
estas cosas que proveen una utilidad y
claro el oro tiene ciertas aplicaciones
no sé por ejemplo puede ser utilizado
como entretenimiento en joyería o
también hay algunas aplicaciones
industriales
creo que en electrónica pero
principalmente es un medio de
intercambio y como medio de intercambio
su principal función es ayudar a las
transacciones de riqueza y con esto
ayudar a la economía a que se ubiquen de
manera eficiente los recursos ahora el
dinero en papel no es escaso de hecho es
controlable
es controlable y también podemos dar una
opinión positiva o negativa de eso
podríamos decir que es flexible eso
sería la parte positiva o podemos decir
que es manipulable o bueno puede ser
manipulable y si en efecto ha habido
momentos en la historia en los cuales
algunos gobiernos simplemente para
seguir con sus planes populistas o no sé
tal vez para posponer los problemas
hasta que haya un nuevo gobierno pues sí
manipulado en el dinero que
eventualmente llevó a una hiperinflación
y el dinero en papel a cabo no valiendo
nada pero claro hay muchos otros
ejemplos en los cuales el dinero en
papel se ha retenido su valor bueno hoy
tenemos otras cositas para pensarlo
ahora regresando a la pregunta de si el
oro va a perder o no va a perder su
valor pues depende contra que estemos
diciendo que está perdiendo su valor y
también pues qué es lo que lo está
causando entonces por ejemplo la gente
podría creer que va a ver sobre
inflación en el dólar por acciones
agresivas en el banco federal de los
eeuu y entonces quieren comprar oro
pues si pueden estar en lo correcto no
estoy seguro de hecho si lo supiera con
mi dinero especularía en oro y la verdad
está pasando lo que pasa detrás de
cualquier inversión siempre cuando uno
hace una inversión pues uno está
haciendo una apuesta acerca de qué va a
ser cierto grupo de personas o qué va a
ser el gobierno federal déjame poner un
ejemplo con el precio del oro con
respecto al dólar
así ajustando todos los dólares en 2009
el oro en 1980 en 1980
1900 le pongo 2009 porque fue una época
como de crisis pero bueno creo que
estaba como en 240 dólares entonces
incluso en esa época en que dije así en
2009 incluso con todo lo que se hablaba
de esto de que podía haber
hiperinflación porque el banco federal
de eeuu estaba haciendo muy agresivo y
estaba haciendo crecer muchas hojas de
balance incluso con eso que se decía en
2009 en precios de esa época pues el
hombre estaba creo que como en 840
dólares ahora de regreso en 1980 en 1980
una persona muy razonable podría haber
dicho madre mía la inflación está súper
alta hemos tenido problemas con el
petróleo la inflación de hecho la
inflación estaba pues mucho más intensa
de lo que ha estado últimamente con esto
podría decir
sabes que yo pienso que el dólar ya no
va a valer nada antes de que nos demos
cuenta
voy a comprar oro la verdad creo que el
oro debe valer mucho más pero cuanto no
sé no sé si 24.000 o si 2 millones o
vaya si el oro se debería ir a infinito
con respecto al dólar o el dólar a cero
con respecto al oro entonces si
cualquier persona razonable pudo haber
hecho un argumento muy
convincente de por qué deberían de sacar
todo el dinero del banco y convertirlo
en oro pero quién iba a predecir que
paul volcker si va a aparecer al
principio de los 80s e iba a aumentar
las tasas de interés incluso bajo la
presión política de hacer lo contrario
con lo cual iba a lograr mantener la
inflación ya fin de cuentas para finales
de los 90
creo que sería bueno escribirlo por aquí
para finales de los 90s otra vez todo en
precios del 2009 el oro estaba como en
los 200 dólares tal vez menos pero
déjame ponerle 200 y mira incluso aunque
esta persona hubiera dicho buenos
finales de los 90
voy a seguir aferrado a mi apuesta con
el oro no sé digamos si se hubieran
aferrado su apuesta hasta el 2009
entonces de todas formas les hubiera
convenido más mantener su dinero en una
cuenta bancaria que da más interés que
la inflación no sé cómo un 2 o 3 por
ciento me hubiera convenido más que
quedarse con el oro incluso cuando había
un argumento tan convincente de
inflación en aquel tiempo entonces es
muy muy difícil predecir qué va a pasar
con cualquiera de estas cosas que son un
medio de intercambio para la riqueza es
bien difícil decir pues esta unidad de
intercambio es tal
y bueno pues con el oro si se ha subido
o sea desde 1990 hasta 2007 subió a 840
dólares y eso puede hacer a las personas
que crean que el dólar va a perder de
valor y pues si es completamente posible
a lo mejor a eeuu le toque un gobierno
súper irresponsable y aunque ahorita la
inflación esté controlada pues en 1 ó 2
años su liquidez empieza a tener un
efecto multiplicador que haga que el
dólar se devasta y que el oro brinque
hacia arriba hacia nos digamos 8 mil
dólares en cuyo caso comprar oro sería
una gran apuesta pero tal vez el
problema no es eso sino es la deflación
tal vez la gente no pierde fe en la
moneda y de repente se nos aparece así
otro polvo que de la nada hacia otras
estrategias para controlar la inflación
y el oro baja 200 otra vez bueno lo que
te quiero decir es que en realidad es
muy difícil de predecir esto tiene mucho
que ver con que no es utilidad por sí
mismo sino nada más ayuda a intercambiar
la pero bueno aunque sea interesante no
me quiero meter mucho en esta discusión
regresemos a lo otro como te contaba hay
otros caminos que pudimos haber tomado
en este árbol de los sistemas bancarios
quiero pasar por la otra rama que es la
que no hemos recorrido en vez de tener
una reserva fraccionaria podríamos tener
un sistema de reserva completa
observa completa así en vez de que
presume deposites y yo te diga que
puedes sacarlo cuando quieras aunque yo
esté prestando digamos el 90% de eso en
vez de eso te diría sabes que el 90% de
tu dinero no lo puedes sacar mañana no
sé digamos que ese dinero se va a quedar
encerrado por seis meses y el dinero que
quieras tener así para mañana lo
apartamos no te voy a pagar interés
incluso tal vez me tengas que pagar un
poquito por mantenerlo seguro y que lo
puedas retirar de un cajero bueno es
otra forma válida de pensar alguien
podría decir que esto es menos flexible
eso sería la parte negativa menos
flexible pero por otro lado la parte
positiva es que es menos susceptible a
ser manipulable menos manipulación y no
sé a lo mejor otra cosa es que no haya
tantos líos a lo mejor no se generan
estas burbujas financieras pero no estoy
totalmente seguro aunque el argumento se
vea más o menos razonable e incluso aquí
podríamos decidir hacer reservas en x
o no hacerlas otra vez eso sería una
cuestión de que hay tanta flexibilidad
queremos por ejemplo el sistema más
estricto sería de reserva completa
basado en una moneda dura que no pueda
ser impresa o bueno que no pueda ser
controlada por humanos hasta cierto
punto o bien puedes permitir esto de
imprimir monedas la cosa es que podría
ser un poquito manipulable es justo como
el sistema de reserva fraccionaria
verdad el respaldo en oro lo hace un
poco menos flexible pero también pues
menos manipulable bueno nada más quería
darte esta perspectiva general porque
creo que la vez pasada me metí en temas
un poco polémicos la verdad de ninguna
forma yo quería insultar al oro de hecho
pues no creo que así de un día para otro
se vuelva algo sin valor sin embargo
quería dejar muy claro esta distinción
que es como filosófica entre el oro y
las cosas que se pueden intercambiar por
él o vaya no sólo del oro sino de
cualquier tipo de dinero de cualquier
tipo de moneda y de las cosas que se
pueden intercambiar por ella ahora creo
que el oro si tiene un valor especial
tiene un valor especial comparado pues
no sé con los diamantes o con nanotubos
o con cualquier otra cosa y eso tiene
con que el oro tiene historia desde el
principio de la historia escrita la
gente ha usado el oro como medio de
intercambio hemos usado tanto el oro que
ya está penetrado así totalmente en
nuestro adn cultural eso es lo que lo
hace tan robusto como moneda pero fuera
de eso pues no es muy distinto de los
diamantes o de los nanotubos de carbono
o de las piedras lunares en fin se me
acabó el tiempo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo